جزر كبير من هذه التحديات وجهه وامريكا
والدول الاوروبيه والمتحول بدا ينتشر هناك
وبسرعه وبارقام مطلقه ربما لم يصل الوضع
لخطوره ما يحصل في الصين حيث غصه
المستشفيات بالمرضى ودور الجنازات بالجثث
لكن الصور قد تتكرر والتشاءم مبرر فامريكا
معرضه لنقص ان ذاتها الطبيه والعهده هنا
على صيام ذلك ان مصنع العالم الصيني طبعا
تعرض لامتكاسه وان كانت خفيفه
فتكرار العمال الصينيين لحملات الاضراب
والتقاطهم للعدوى يهدد جداول سلاسل
التوريد التي تمتلك الصين الحصه الاكبر
منها علميا تعطل الماكينه البشريه الصينيه
يؤثر على العالم في الصين لا تسالوا اكبر
مصدر للاقنعه والقفازات والارضيات الطبيه
حتى مكونات الادويه الاساسيه اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده وحدها استوردت ادويه من
الصين بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات ومئتين مليون
دولار
مدعم مقدول في فرنسا مثلا لا يتجاوز عدد
الادويه المصنعه على اراضيها العشرين في
المئه الباقي ياتي من الخارج والغالبيه
تاتي من الصين وفي بريطانيا واحده من كل
صفه مواطبيه حيويه مستخدمه في المستشفيات
تاتي من الصين وذلك بحسب تحقيق نشر في
مايو 2012
مثال اخر خلال الربيع الماضي اضطر اطباء
امريكيون لي تاجيل عمليات جراحيه بعد تاخر
وصول 10 الاف
وركزت على الانتاج المحلي وها هي ستون في
المئه من الشركات التصنيع تسارع لاستبدال
خياراتها بالهند
كل هذا القلق ياتي تزامن ان مع اكبر حركه
بشريه في العالم
وهكذا هي الصين حتى في اعيادها تظهر قوتها
البشريه فيما يعرف بيتشونيون الصينيه اي
حركه الربيع هذه النقاط توضح كيف بدا
الصينيون بالانتشار النشاط الروسده من 100
في مدينه والمتوقع وصول العدد الى 400
مليون مهاجر للاحتفال بالسنه القمريه
الجديده العمال والطلاب حزموا الامتعه على
ان يلحقهم الموظفون بيت العائله هو الوجه
الاخيره اما البعض الاخر فاختاره ان يقضي
اجازته خارج البلاد بعد ثلاث سنوات من
الاغلاق رسميا ينطلقوا العيد الوطني غدا
في الحادي والعشرين من يناير يستمر لسبعه
ايام لكن الهجره الواسعه تستمر لاسابيع 40
يوما تحديدا بدات في السابع من يناير
وتنتهي في الحادي والعشرين من فبراير وهنا
الخطا اذا ان الهجره تجري في ظل انتشار
الفيروس ومتحوله الجديد اي ان الصين تخاطر
بالفتح وتعرض اقل من ربع سكان العالم
مقاليا لخطر العدوى من ربما تخاطر لنشر
العدوى في كل بقاع الارض توفقا لتوقعاتي
وزاره النقل ستجرى نحو ثلاثه مليارات رحله
داخليه وخارجيه خلال احتفالات هذا العام
ومعظمها تسجل حركه مغادره
وحركه دخول وخروج من والى بكين المخاطر
الكبرى تتعلق بالمسنين الحلقه الاضعف في
في مواجهه الفيروس فالهجره تجريف المناطق
الحضريه الى الريفيه الاقل تجهيزا باسره
العنايه واجهزه التنفس حيث يقصن غانبيات
كبار السن بالغ عددهم رئتين والخمسين
مليون